[Musique]
on peut doit tuer j'espère qu'à dieu mon
rituel
c'est en diffusant des films comme ce
long métrage polonais que le ciné 7 est
aujourd'hui lavez les et recherches et
découvertes
une reconnaissance décernée par la fnaca
et l'association française des cinémas
art et essai sont les films peu diffusé
dans les salles cinéma européen cinéma
mondial qui sortent sur des petites
combinaisons de copies très souvent
version originale des films peu diffusé
donc en france voilà peu exposé que
public a du mal à trouver dans les
salles
donc ce cinéma là il faut le montrer
aussi il faut l'exposé il faut le mettre
en lumière et des films découvert lors
de festivals comme celui de cannes ou
par des coups de coeur de l'équipe du
cinéma et du public
ce label est décerné pour les deux
années à venir c'est le troisième que
reçoit le signer cette classé art et
essai depuis 1994 et ça vient couronner
un travail vraiment d'equipe un travail
de programmation réalisée par les
équipes ici sous la houlette de luc
beaucamp et puis c'est un bonne nouvelle
aussi bien entendu pour les spectateurs
qui viennent le voir puisque c'est à la
fois le gage comme j'ai toujours dit
d'un éclectisme culturelle dans ce
cinéma complet on a une palette complète
de toute l'actualité cinématographique
on va bien entendu de l'art essais mais
ce sont également les blockbusters il
faut pas les oublier parce qu'on a aussi
une clientèle qui vient pour les voir la
salle élan courtoise projette chaque
année entre 350 et 366 mhz le signer cet
accueil plus de 100000 cinéphiles